Justin Warren: Okay, next question.
Film Courage: Okay and this is from Iglp3.
Here is my question, my name is Chloe.
How do you stay the course in spite of the
inner negative narrative so many writers deal
with that says “everything you make sucks?”
Justin: Man…that’s a good question…Oh!
That’s rich, that’s really rich.
Oh man!
Film Courage: You’ve got us Chloe.
Justin: Wow!
Yeah, I feel like I can speak on this for
days.
I would say in particular…I don’t want
to get too dark here but I think writing is
inherently like the only person you are battling
is yourself really (most of the time).
And I think in particular at least for me
I can only speak for my own experience, I
struggle a lot with self-hatred.
There are lots of parts of myself that I hate.
And I am only just now sort of getting over
those types of things but when it’s just
you and a blank screen and a cursor flashing
sometimes all of your insecurities and bubble
up and it gets in the way of you getting your
creative thoughts on the page.
And I’ve learned just for me like when I’m
able to give myself permission to write the
worst, most terrible pages of all time then
I can do it.
And then in my back pocket I know that writing
is process.
So I know that whatever I try on my first
attempt is probably not going to be very good.
In fact the terrible first draft, that’s
just kind of a law in how I see it.
There are other people who are brilliant that
can pump out a genius first draft, I’m not
that person, I will never be that person.
And so for me when I’m allowed to give myself
grace and allow myself to write terribly,
to just write things that don’t make sense,
to write sentence fragments…
“And then they fight…I’ll come back
later.”
And then keep going, you know what I mean?
Like when I allow myself that level of freedom,
then I can write.
I feel like on paper I shouldn’t be a writer
because my self-criticism in my brain is pretty
fierce and sometimes it’s unbearable.
But I think you do, you have to give yourself
grace.
You have to…I don’t want to be too new-agey
but you’ve got to kind of love yourself.
I mean you have to be okay with “Yep, these
are some terrible words, but you know they
are words and that’s all that matters right
now.”
In this particular instance, the only thing
that matters is putting words on the page,
they don’t have to be the right words, they
don’t have to be in the right order.
And at least for a first draft that’s the
thing that when I learned that sort of unlocked
in my brain.
It’s like “Oh, this draft doesn’t count.
It doesn’t count because I can go back and
fix it later.”
And so writing with a reckless abandon.
Like this doesn’t have to be good.
This is supposed to be bad.
Anyone can write a terrible thing, you know
what I mean (terrible just in terms of the
mechanics of words).
Anyone can write something terrible and that’s
how I find my entry into it.
I know for a fact that I can write something
terrible.
If my goal is to sit down and be a genius,
I can’t hit that every day.
But I can hit being really bad every day.
And so that’s my only metric of success
are there words on the page?
Yes.
My metric of success is not are they good
words, is this good?
That’s for later.
Film Courage: I’ve probably mentioned this
before but there is this thing called the
Dunning-Kruger effect and I’m probably butchering
the name of it but I think it’s something
to the effect of those who think they are
really horrible at something are actually
better than most people.
I’m not sure I may be butchering this concept
but then those who think that “I’m really
good at this” they are actually mistaken
and it’s this weird duality.
So people who are more (I don’t know if
the word is self-effacing) they are actually
better than what they think they are doing.
So I don’t know, that’s just something
that came to mind.
Justin: That kind of makes sense, I think
there might be something to that because I
think you have to be relatively self-aware
(well, I guess you don’t have to be).
But I think self-awareness as a writer is
a good thing.
But self-awareness gone unchecked can be unproductive.
But if you can find a mechanism in a way that
you can use that as a tool as a way to look
at something critically and look at it later
critically, that’s a really good skill to
have because it allows you to empathize with
people which is really all that we’re trying
to do in our stories is create empathy between
the audience and the characters, that’s
all we’re trying to do.
And I think people that might think “I’m
terrible at this.”
I know I’m in that crowd, I think that can
be a strength when used like a tool used in
a very calculated way like “Okay, I wrote
this thing.
It’s really bad.
I know it’s bad.
How can I make it good?”
In that sort of not assuming that you have
all the answers I think can open you up to
making much more work long term.
Film Courage: It reminds me of the two characters
in ADAPTATION?
Justin: Yeah!
Love that movie.
Film Courage: So you see the one character
[Charlie Kaufman] played by Nicholas Cage
is insecure and you know there is so much
he can do but it’s just a matter of what
he feels about himself.
And the other guy [Donald Kaufman, also played
by Nicholas Cage]…
Justin: Is just pumping it out and it like
“I think I sold this already?”
Film Courage: Women on both arms, nice cars,
nice things and it doesn’t make sense but
you see this sometimes in life and you wonder
how is that possible?
Well I think it’s just someone’s perception
of themselves.
It’s this weird thing.
Justin: Absolutely.
Film Courage: Because if you think you’re
terrible you are probably not going to get
the words out.
And so when I feel like for me I shouldn’t
even be a writer because I struggle so much
with self-hatred.
But I learned if you just give yourself permission
to be terrible, you can do it because everybody
can be really bad at something.
I think there’s a John Lennon quote where
he’s like “I’m a musician, if you hand
me a tuba, I’ll get something out of it.”
And I’m like “I get that now."
He didn’t say it would be good, he just
said I could get something out of this.
And I think if we create from that perspective,
especially with first drafts and first attempts
with things, you really can’t go wrong because
anybody can probably get something out of
a tuba.
Film Courage: It might hurt your ears at first,
but then it would get better.
Justin: It could shatter all the glass in
the room, but that’s okay.